hi in this video I will talk about
allergy which is otherwise known as type
1 hypersensitivity reaction so the
hypersensitivity means your immune
system is hypersensitive the immune
system generally protects our body from
external pathogen attack and viral or
bacterial attack but when the immune
system is hyperactive then a situation
is created which is known as
hypersensitivity instead of doing good
to our body it actually harms our body
and we would look at how this happens
now among 300 million u.s. population
roughly about 100 million people are
suffering from allergies and the trend
of increasing allergy is in is randomly
increasing day by day also in the third
world countries like India Malaysia
Vietnam etc the trend of getting more
allergy is increasing so people are
allergic to some time gluten sometimes
has my seed eggs sometimes even
crustaceans like prawns or otherwise
peanuts etc etc now some allergens are
some substances which cause allergy are
called allergies for example pollen
grains otherwise substances present in
bee sting could also cause allergy for
some people also substance is present in
dust mite or cockroaches are also
allergy for some people also there are
many food substances to which people are
allergic
now some allergens are very complex and
they have enzymatic activity mostly they
have proteins like activity allergens
found in cockroaches and bedbugs have
this proteus kind of activity and they
cleave the tight junctions
between the epithelial cells which is
making these cells even more loosen
allowing the allowing more pathogen to
enter or damages this cell or Luth or
also decrease the integrity of the cell
other Proteus such as trip one produced
by a dust mite cleave active complement
cascades and thereby creating
inflammatory responses now let's say
this person is inhaling a pollen grain
the pollen grain would go from its nasal
pathway and it would end up in the
alveoli where in the alveoli the perfect
of the pollen grains would enter the
epithelial cells now in the inside the
epithelial cell layer there are several
cellular players like P cells and these
B cells and this epithelial cellular
layer is pretty reaching high GD
producing B cells there are also
patrolling macrophages and dendritic
cells now once a b-cell encounters a
pathogen it engulfs that pathogen and
displayed a pathogen on to the surface
of its onto its surface by plus two MHC
and this is displayed to a th2 type cd4
positive T helper cell now th two
positive cd4 helper cell would secrete
interleukin 4 and that interleukin 4
signalling would allow differentiation
of IG producing B cell to plasma cell a
plasma cells which secrete are held out
of antibody an IgE
is one of the important mediator of
allergy now type 1 hypersensitivity is
solely dependent on IgE antibodies some
people have more IG in their blood while
all the normal people have very less
titer of IG in their serum so ite
no more number of IgE or more th to sell
these kind of based things are actually
genetically predisposed it so this
allergy could have a genetic basis also
some people are referred to atopic are
more prone to allergy so in some
families allergy is quite prevalent to a
particular substance now another key
player of the immune cell immune system
is the Marcel Marcel has specific
receptors for antibodies which are known
as FC receptors now
FC receptors who interact with the IgE
molecules and they will become a
sensitized mast cell and the second time
when the body would encounter the same
allergy then there would be a huge
reaction in the mast cells and the mast
cells would drink D granulate now once
muscle D granulate it would do a tons of
things including smooth muscle
contraction vasodilation
bronchoconstriction or glandular
secretion
now what happens when for the second
time the allergen is binding to a I GE
receptor IgE molecule in the IgE
molecule is actually bound to the
surface receptor on the mast cell the FC
receptors
now the FC receptors have immune
receptor tyrosine kinase but activation
motif several kindnesses of limb family
cross phosphorylates the items of the
receptor c-terminal domain and thereby
ultimately activating map kinase
signaling pathway or PKC signaling
pathway which ultimately give rise to
transcription of several players all of
which can ultimately help in production
of inflammatory mediators like
prostaglandin leukotriene histamine or
other inflammatory cytokines
one of the most important mediators was
history histamine is a biological
combine or a modified version of a mine
which would bind to the GPCR histamine
receptor histamine receptors are of
broadly three types histamine receptor
one our histamine receptor 2 or X term
intercepted 3 roughly right now
histamine receptor 4 is also discovered
all this different histamine receptor
and histamine II interaction would lead
to different signaling cascades in
inside the cell now all these things but
ultimately lead to increased
vasodilation gas increased gastric
secretions increased bio bowel
peristalsis and also bronchoconstriction
now all these inflammatory mediators and
all these kind of mediators which are
produced by by the action of by the
action of interleukins the
prostaglandins leukotrienes that
histamines etc etc all these things when
ultimately lead to smooth muscle
construction which would work on neurons
it would affect the vascular epithelial
cell it would also affect the
hematopoietic cells to increase
hematopoiesis it will also work on
epithelial cells all these things need
to change
its functionality from a few hour time
point to for a few days it would evoke
inflammation then it would generally
lead to a huge change in function and
ultimately it would cause in a
remodeling of tissue now apart from the
activity of the B cell and the th2
helper cell another important factor is
the dendritic cell the dendritic cell
can also engulf the allergen here the
pollen grain and can display that onto
its surface bound MHC class 2 molecule
it can go and migrate towards the lymph
node which is the
base camp for T lymphocytes and B
lymphocytes now it can activate the
t-cells there and after T cell
activation the D cell the T helper cell
can interact with the B cell and the B
cell would ultimately give rise to
antibody producing IgE type IgE type
antibody producing plasma cells which
means it would secrete even more IgE
antibodies into the bloodstream and it
would make it would work in a vicious
cycle to increase the halachic responses
now the manifestation of the allergic
allergic responses includes redness
rashes in the skin sometimes watering of
the eyes tearing and something running
nose or increased mucus secretion etc
etc now what is the test for allergic
responses so there is a allergic
response state test in which several
points in the hands are marked hands or
the shoulder is marked and then little
bit suspected allergy is injected there
or the portion where you can see the
marks are cut and a little bit amount of
substances are there and after about 30
minutes or so it is checked for redness
and swelling if you find redness and
swelling that means those are the
potential allergen to which the person
is allergic and this is one of the
important tests for a large now
treatment to allergy includes
anti-inflammatory medications and based
way to avoid allergy is to avoid the
food or the substances to which you are
allergic another interesting aspect of
it is using antibody as a treatment
Omalu zoom map is one of the antibody
which binds to the FC region of the IgE
antibody since IgE is one of the most
important mediator of allergy if you
inhibit IG IgE then I GU cannot bind to
the FC receptors on the mass
and cannot make the Marcel 2d grenade
and secret all these inflammatory
mediators and thereby suppressing the
allergy in my next video I would talk
about anti allergic medication in
details and the mode of their action so
if you like my video give it a quick
thumbs up don't forget to like share and
subscribe thank you